So this is HIV.
It's a typical retrovirus,
meaning that it has an outer envelope. And in the center it has two copies of RNA,
as well as an enzyme, here in blue,
that's reverse transcriptase,
which will ultimately turn that RNA into DNA.
The virus itself,
with this outer envelope protein actually directly
infects T helper cells.
The way that it does this, is that as it comes up to the cell's surface,
it uses receptors that are on T helper cells, and exclusive to T helper
cells,
which are CD4 for molecule,
which really defines T helper cells,
it's a surface receptor that binds to the envelope protein. That
causes a confirmational change and allows a second receptor to grab hold of the
envelope.
This is the Chemokine coreceptor,
it's also called CCR5,
and we'll talk about that more.
What happens now is that the stock of the envelope protein
pierces through from the virus into the host
cell and starts to draw the two cell memberanes-- the cell membrane in the viral membrane
together.
And what ultimately happens is fusion of those two membranes and the viral genetic
material is injected essentially into the cell,
and the envelope protein is left at the cell surface.
The virus has a matrix and a capsid protein, shown here in green and red, that
essentially are digested when it enters into the cell. That releases
viral enzymes in the viral RNA. And here we have reverse
transcriptase,
which takes the viral RNA, and using host
nucleotides,
converts that viral RNA into a single strand of DNA.
While it does that it makes some random errors,
which is characteristic of reverse transcriptase,
it has very poor proofreading activity. That single-stranded
DNA now is again reverse transcribed into a double-stranded
DNA.
At that point,
another enzyme that has come in with the virus in the beginning,
called integrase,
essentially grabs hold of that double stranded DNA, and carries it through a
nuclear pore into the nucleus of the cell.
Within the nucleus of the cell,
it finds the host chromosome and it basically the integrase enzyme
makes a nick in the host DNA and allows for HIV to
insert itself into the host chromosome.
And that right there, is what establishes lifelong infection.
Now, RNA polymerase comes along and makes mRNA. Those
mRNAs encode for different viral proteins.
They end up associating with ribosomes at the surface of the rough endoplasmic
reticulum.
And here's a piece of mRNA that's making envelope protein,
which is directly produced into the endoplasmic reticulum,
and it's shuttled then through the endoplasmic reticulum,
and taken to the cell's surface,
where,
at the cell's surface, it becomes embedded in the cellular membrane, and at this
point, coalescing with other envelope proteins that have been produced,
you have this cluster of envelope proteins now on the surface of this infected
cell.
At the same time,
there are other mRNAs that are being produced that allow for
translation of other viral proteins.
So here are additional viral proteins being made,
which we're going to be used to make up the key components that the
virus ultimately is going to need.
These are transported again to the cell surface to the area where these envelope proteins
are, and a strand of RNA, as well as some of the enzymes,
are part of that complex.
This then buds off at the cell surface at this point,
but it's still not a mature virion,
because the polyprotein chain needs to still be
digested into its component parts.
That's done by an enzyme called protease. Protease breaks up those
polyprotein chains, and ultimately allows for them to coalesce and
form the mature structures that make up the final
virion.
And now you have a mature,
infectious,
virion that can go on now to infect other cells.
Once that happens now,
the cell can produce tons of viruses,
and this is really what then keeps the whole process going.